no
[Música]
hola que tal bienvenidos a la entrevista
de france 24 y vamos a hablar con uno de
los pesos pesados de la esgrima campeón
olímpico en espada cinco veces campeón
de copas del mundo cuatro veces campeón
en juegos panamericanos e integrante del
salón de la fama entre muchos otros en
reconocimientos nació en ciudad bolívar
venezuela y vive en polonia desde boots
es un placer para mí saludar a rubén
limardo rubén muchísimas gracias
bienvenidos france24
verdad gracias a ustedes por esta
invitación de verdad que como atleta no
siempre representa a su país con mucho
orgullo en esta oportunidad cada logro
que va logrando es para no solamente
para vivir sola sino para todo el
continente sobre toda sudamérica porque
bueno siempre se motiva pues a estos
chicos de glee mitad de todo el
continente que siempre están en busca de
estas medallas no solamente a nivel del
continente sino a nivel olímpico y
campeonatos mundiales entonces bueno
siempre estaré aquí para inspirar y para
darle triunfo en el país hablando de
triunfos vienes de muy buenas
celebraciones vienes de ganar el gran
premio de budapest a comienzos de marzo
en berna a finales del año pasado
también ganaste de los últimos cuatro
eventos de la copa mundo has ganado dos
podemos decir que estás viviendo a los
36 años una segunda juventud
y bueno de verdad bastante bonito lo que
es lo que he estado logrando un buen
comienzo primera vez en una temporada
donde ley y yo
de esta manera de tres de cuatro
competencias que se han celebrado el
ganado dos pero bueno una no participe
porque un día antes de viajar a doha
qatar en un gran prix también el todo el
equipo sería positivo al cob y al me
imagino que los micro pero la verdad es
que bueno pues inició esto me da a mí
una oportunidad grande de puntear para
ganar la copa del mundo que es la
sumatoria de todos los puntos de las
competencias internacionales entre éstas
están el campeonato panamericano el
campeonato mundial los gran prix copa
del mundo pues buenas pero seguir hacia
nuestros resultados por ahora logre
estos competencias que son muy
importantes e históricas lágrimas
mundial y bueno mi primer grand prix
llegó en esta oportunidad siempre soñaba
con este evento también pero bueno creo
que hay que seguir trabajando un buen
inicio y lo que hemos estado haciendo
está funcionando un momento yo cambié mi
manera de alimentarme el profesor
humberto cambió
un sistema desde la táctica en la
esgrima el tema que contigo el mismo con
con su experiencia y con sus y con su
cabeza se puede decir que nos planteó
estaba entrenamiento y de verdad que
está este sistema que creó el de cinco
pasos me ha ayudado muchísimo bueno
hasta ahora está funcionando y creo que
lo más importante para elegir mi habla
es precisamente de cambios tienen que
ver esos cambios con lo que pasó en los
juegos olímpicos de tokio fueron unos
juegos en los que tú llegaste con mucha
ilusión pero perdiste en ese primer
combate contra román canon que iba a ser
el eventual campeón como fue recuperarse
de ese momento para ahora estar
exhibiendo este gran nivel
bueno yo creo que todo se dice en esta
visión muy muy rápido en el sentido de
que bueno si se hubiese celebrado cuando
olímpico en el año 2020 yo creo que
hubiese hecho un mejor resultado porque
ya venía subiendo el ritmo
venía ya posicionándome en la copa del
mundo había quedado tercero en a comprar
uno de canadá ese mismo año del 2020
pero bueno como pueden ver en la
pandemia y esto es como que frena un
poco el ritmo de muchos atletas se puede
decir como pueden ver en el juego
olímpico hubo muchas sorpresas la
esgrima la espada masculina es un arma
que es bastante difícil que nunca nunca
puede decir quién va a ganar porque es
la más difícil de circuito y bueno como
pueden ver se terminó ganando román
carmel yo creo que bastante difícil para
no solamente para mí sino para todos no
porque ir a unos juegos olímpicos
solamente con participar en una
competencia que se estaba definiendo los
lugares los puestos que faltaban por
clasificarse no entonces es bastante
difícil porque porque una sola
competencia ante tokio
simplemente entrenaba entrenaba pero no
había enfoque no había porque tú tengas
analizar
obviamente fui con todas las
expectativas porque no se dio
lamentablemente pero bueno el trabajo lo
sigo realizando esta party 2024 y
como siempre le hizo para mí los juegos
olímpicos es una competencia importante
por una competencia más y no hay que
detenerse por una derrota simplemente
hay que seguir avanzando y bueno ahí
está la perseverancia e iniciando una
buena temporada de este año y espero que
se mantenga así hasta nuestros próximos
juegos olímpicos eso me llama la
atención en lo vuelves a decir ya lo
dijiste que vayan contando conmigo para
2024 si vamos ahora mismo el ranking de
la federación internacional de esgrima
eres segundo o sea que tengan cuidado
contigo
y bueno como pueden ver quien está
dominando el ranking mundial es el
campeón olímpico román terna después
este resultado que logre en budapest me
posiciona como el número 2 no sabía que
iba a sumar tantos puntos pero la verdad
que esto me da a mí
como se hizo una confianza para luchar
por esos puntos y quizás pueda
arrebatarle ese es el primer lugar al
campeón y para él es más difícil porque
él tiene que llegar al campeonato
mundial y volver a ganarlo porque el
campeonato mundial para sumar la
cantidad junto en cambio yo simplemente
tengo un 32 que fue la primera ronda y
todo lo que haga de ahí para arriba o
sea sumatoria hay un derechazo de ganar
esta competencia pero bueno esperemos
que se mantenga ese ritmo y que se
mantenga este trabajo que estamos
haciendo de verdad que yo me siento a
otro nivel en cuanto a gran madurez y
bueno espero que ese pueblo grandes
objetivos pero más allá de este objetivo
no apresurarse porque bueno 36 año
hay que ponerse muy bien hay que
administrar la gasolina hasta los juegos
olímpicos de parís o minuto 4 pero no
solamente uso individual sino que
estamos preparando también el equipo
porque es en esta oportunidad todos que
no se dio un equipo joven entonces
tenemos que abrir el lujo de sublimar
los chicos pero 25 años 26 años y creo
que ya experimentaron lo que era una
clasificación ahora creo que con todo
para el país y espero estar con mi
equipo porque van a sueño también con
que mi hermano logra una medalla
olímpica yo te voy a preguntar por ese
equipo pero querías hacer antes hincapié
en que en la copa mundo de vancouver en
2021 te ganaste la medalla de bronce
pero un horno a copa mundo no lo ganaba
desde 2003 se ha pasado bastante tiempo
hoy en día como son tus condiciones
actuales de entrenamiento antes de tokio
se hicieron virar estas imágenes
trabajando como repartidor y
recientemente contase que para ir a la
cita de hungría tu equipo y tuvieron que
conducir desde polonia en un propio auto
pienso que siempre tenemos esa
dificultad no únicamente valorista con
el tema de los recursos no sabemos qué
pasará corporal estamos quedando con
nuestros propios costos como pueden ver
el profesor un persona viajado las
últimas dos competencias porque no se
mostrarán los recursos he decidido
mandarlo tu entrenador que se llama
vendí martínez que está con nosotros
pero bueno eso es parte de todo esto
viajamos budapest internos porque es más
económico porque tal entre ese más
barato que dicen en vuelos comerciales
obviamente un boleto ahorita en europa
es costosísimo sobre todo por la pareja
porque no hay tantas conexiones como
antes pero bueno de este tipo de eventos
que nos queda hacer cada ocho horas
podemos ver sin ningún problema pero lo
importante es que estemos siempre hay
participando que no frente no nos
quedemos sin ir a ninguna competencia
porque esto nos da un análisis de cómo
estamos nosotros a nivel de a nivel
mundial si lo que estamos haciendo está
funcionando y eso es gracias al equipo
de trabajo que tenemos los entrenadores
de alguna otra manera van chequear cómo
va el trabajo bueno hasta ahora
y todos los que han implementado ha
venido funcionando un poco o sea mi
parte funciona porque todos los que me
han dado la experiencia y la madurez que
tengo me ha ayudado muchísimo pues ahora
no solamente
están los resultados míos sino que
gabriel lugo en la competencia pasada en
sochi rusia logró un lugar donde 16
eliminando en la ronda de 32 al campeón
olímpico del río 2016
oriana que poco a poco se va dando este
trabajo y lo más importante es que
siempre tenemos que tener competencia lo
importante en la manera que tengamos que
viajar si es que hay muchas obras viajar
tres días pero importante estar ahí para
poder seguir participando
fogueándose y analizar todo lo que
estamos haciendo lo importante es estar
ahí pero efectivamente mejoras de esas
duras condiciones siempre de 24 hemos
venido denunciando esas deudas que hay
por parte del gobierno de venezuela con
algunos deportistas de alto rendimiento
hablamos con el entrenador de rebeldes
peinado de la moza incluso con tu
entrenador y tío ruperto gascón cuál es
la situación en este contexto de rubén
limardo
bueno por ahora bueno obviamente en
tokio de alguna otra manera ese apoyo
porque estaba clasificado
por lo que tengo entendido ahora cómo
está iniciando la temporada
bastante difícil
por los recursos supuestamente
a mediados de este año ya debería estar
saliendo los recursos esperemos que así
sea porque bueno ya tokio perdón por los
juegos olímpicos de parís en dos años se
realizan ya el año que viene iniciamos
la clasificación y de alguna otra manera
el apoyo tiene que estar porque buenos
primeros en los resultados no los
resultados demuestran por sí solo y de
contra manera tiene que seguir apoyando
el equipo lo ofrezco en el entrenador
que que no sabemos yo lo mencioné ya
está en una situación bastante difícil y
lo estamos viendo ya varios soportes de
trabajo en otros países y yo creo que si
sigue así se va a ir y nosotros
tendremos que regresar a venezuela no sé
aún cómo ver a otro lugar porque
nosotros vamos aquí por él y bueno el
plan de buscar otro país que nos brinden
esta oportunidad de poder trabajar en
este caso siempre es romper esto se va
con otro país nosotros tendríamos que
buscar la manera de amarrar a 20 y
martín el otro entrenador pero espero
que esto suceda de ser así se va a
complicar bastante sobre todo para los
olímpicos
yo creo que de alguna otra manera tienen
que solucionarlo pero el problema es que
no se ve una intención porque el
profesor humberto estaba luchando del
2016 con con el contrato que si le van a
pagar 39 a pagar de otra manera en el
momento le da un poquito agarre por aquí
profe pero ya no hay nada firmado 16 no
puedo vivir así después posea no tiene
un contrato no le pagan consecuentemente
desde el 2016
entonces aprueban unos recursos es bueno
este recursos para el equipo pero no
dicen así sí sí hay que pagarle al
entrenador o no y lo que lo que dan es a
veces muy poco entonces tenemos que
hacer milagros con lo que recibimos para
poder viajar a todas las competiciones
he hecho muchas federaciones
internacionales que tienen contacto con
el pro feliz en que cómo hacer para
sustentar a un equipo de trabajo grande
espías de eta prácticamente y sobre todo
de las pandemias no regresamos a
venezuela porque nosotros frecuentemente
viajamos venezuela x acción meses y el
gasto no sé no se generaba
constantemente pero bueno últimamente
desde la pandemia nuevos rayos a
venezuela y sabes
tienen que trabajar día a día de taxi
para poder pagarlas leyendo la comida y
bueno como puedes ver la gasolina
aumentando sé de verdad que es bastante
difícil pues yo tengo entendido que
atleta en otros países tienen becas muy
altas sobre todo en colombia que cobran
los atletas de clima de verdad que son
bien pagados y de verdad no sé después
quizás por la situación que te pase
miles sobre la comunicación todo esto
desconozco porque tengo años que no
reviso licitar la cuenta bancaria mi
país pero lo importante es que o sea
esperemos que esto esto es todo no se
vaya más allá de las manos y podemos
recibir siempre ese apoyo así sea un
poco tarde pero que llegue para nosotros
puedes seguir preparando para el próximo
juego ni rubén muy rápidamente cuál es
el futuro de la esgrima en venezuela
bueno de verdad que
yo lo veo bastante difícil porque si hay
gente que dice que están trabajando allá
pero no están trabajando a nivel o sea
hacer publicidad es decir están haciendo
competencia están haciendo esto no
quiere decir que que van a tener grandes
resultados porque no tienen a los
capacitados no tienen a los
profesionales y como pueden ver pues lo
único que toda la vida los resultados a
nivel internacional es el equipo que
está bajo el mando entre personas compre
del resto como puedes ver en lima 2019
en los juegos panamericanos venezuela se
llevó 6 medalla y de esa semilla 5 fue
el proyecto ruperto se las compre
entonces una sola por parte de la
operación y quizás en puede ser la
operación porque es de las tres andrea
benítez que ella siempre ha estado en el
circuito internacional y de alguna
manera siempre ha tenido su preparación
pero no es una gestión de la operación
entonces la verdad que no sabemos qué va
a pasar obviamente está trabajando
espero que eso tenga su fruto pero lo
veo bien difícil sin ninguna
participación en evento internacionales
no lo van a lograr rubén mensaje
contundente de cara a la situación de
lágrimas venezuela muchísimas gracias
por habernos acompañado en este tiempo
en la entrevista de france 24 siempre
nos va a quedar parís mucha suerte para
lo que viene que ojalá tengamos en lo
más alto del ranking gracias también
ustedes por habernos acompañado en este
espacio quédense en la pantalla de
france 24 porque la información continúa
aquí mientras 24 punto com
[Música]